Rolling Stone uh
published this article yesterday
all week long a culture War has been
raging around country star Jason
Aldean's try that in a small town a
turgid power ballad wrapped around an
unsubtle warning to protesters and other
Outsiders
try that in a small town see how far you
make it down the road quoting the song
to many observers that sounds
uncomfortably close to the kind of
threat that the clan used to issue to
civil rights activists and that modern
day racists continue to spout today the
music video is juxtaposa's stock footage
of Canadian protesters with scenes set
at the site of a 1927 lynching didn't
help dispel that impression
Scholars have noted the obvious
parallels oh the scholars we've heard
from the so the scholars have chimed in
on this on this pop song and they've
noticed the uncomfortable parallels
between try that in a small town and
white nationalist ideology Aldean claims
he's just singing about community and
neighborly Harmony
the good part says the article says some
right-wing trolls though don't want you
to think too hard about any of that
they'd rather talk about rap music
alleged Republican presidential
candidate Vivek ramaswamy is moaning
about Ice T's 1992 song cop killer and
sex and violence and Hip-Hop frequent
hate Monger Matt Walsh whines that
nearly every rap song for the past 30
years has directly in enthusiastically
glorified murder drug dealing robbery
and every other violent crime and these
people say nothing true
um TV comedian turned far-right Fringe
voice Roseanne Barr got in on the Act 2
with a salty tweet about gangster rap
this is a familiar pattern to Rolling
Stone says to anyone who's paid
attention to the past few Decades of
conservative punditry when the heat gets
too high in the right wing they try to
change the subject to hip-hop it's why
when shock jock Don Imus was Under Fire
for his nasty racist remarks about the
Rutgers Women's Basketball team in 2007.
some people wanted to talk about
rapper's language instead
it's why Bill O'Reilly okay so we're
going so they're cute so I like he's
accusing us of changing the subject and
bringing up the ancient past
um and then he goes immediately to Don
Imus
and Bill O'Reilly
examples from 2007 and 2003 respectively
but this is always the game is to say oh
well you're this is what about ISM
you're changing the subject no we're not
changing this yes it is a what about
but guess what what about arguments are
completely valid
yes maybe we've attached ISM to it
but that doesn't mean that it's not
valid
so yes all of what about argument does
it's a way of of establishing
that you that this this principle that
you're espousing you don't apply
consistently so you you have stated a
principle you've made a statement you've
applied it to this one very localized
area
and we're saying well what about all
these things over here that this would
also apply to
what about those
part of the what about is to is to is
try to try to get to what you're
actually saying
what what point are you actually trying
to make
so on this topic
uh on the left in the media they're
pretending to be terribly scandalized by
Violence by violent rhetoric in a song
right and they're they're worried about
what it might encourage people to do and
what it might provoke
they're saying things like the the song
is dangerous
and what we're saying is okay if you're
worried about violent lyrics in songs
what about
all of this stuff over here what about
like almost every rap song that's ever
been made
does
that there's there's a lot of violence
there and it's it's much more explicit
and we laid this out a few days ago not
only is it much more explicit but uh
whereas Jason Aldean if he's encouraging
violence at all or talking about it in a
favorable way he's talking about
violence in defense of the innocent
violence and defense of your community
violence and self-defense
which yeah those are all good kinds of
violence not all violence is made equal
not all violence is bad violence and
defense of the innocent violence and
defense of yourself that is good is a
good form of violence
it's not good that it comes to that
but it's it's it is um
it is good to defend yourself and defend
the innocent
so that's what he's talking about
whereas the big difference with violence
and a lot of rap songs is that while
it's being explicitly promoted and
glorified
by people who by the way oftentimes have
actually engaged in this kind of
violence themselves and are bragging
about it
uh on top of that the violence they're
talking about is not violence and
defense of the innocent or in defense of
anyone
even self-defense
it's violence just to prove how tough
you are it's violence uh you know it's
violence motivated by greed you're
robbing someone it's violence motivated
by just pure indifference to human life
so it is entirely valid for us to say
well if you have an issue with violence
and music why are you giving all of that
a pass
so you're proposing that something is a
problem you're skipping over all of the
worst examples of that problem
and you're you're sifting through all of
that
you're digging through all of it you're
discarding eye doesn't matter that
doesn't matter that doesn't matter
until you find this one little thing
to pin the whole issue on
that's what we're pointing out
because if we are going to have any kind
of meaningful conversation about
violence and music violence and media
that could be a worthwhile conversation
but it's not a worthwhile conversation
if we don't get the full picture first
we don't get the full picture of what
we're of what we're dealing with
I go on here but I'm not going to
um
this Rolling Stone article do they get
to the point in the article of actually
dealing
with these comparisons like explaining
so you're upset about the Jason Aldean
thing you don't care about any of this
stuff with the rap music why is that why
is all of that violent rhetoric in like
literally thousands of rap songs through
the decades why is all of that okay
and it doesn't concern you and you never
bring it up
he never gets around to engaging with
that question or answering it of course
because there is no answer
all they can do is uh is point at what
we're saying and say what about ISM
doesn't count
oh you see you see if you bring up our
hypocrisy and our double standards
um then it it that's it is automatically
invalid to bring up our hypocrisy and
double standards
very convenient it's clear to the left
is giving up their morals and any Common
Sense there's no better time than to
build a daily habit of prayer and
meditation building a habit of prayer
can help you cultivate an attitude of
gratitude focusing on what you're
thankful for can increase positive
emotions and improve overall well-being
hello is the number one Christian Prayer
app in the U.S it's helped me maintain a
daily prayer routine and it can help you
do the same download the app for free at
hello.com Matt Walsh you can set prayer
reminders and track your progress along
the way not sure where to start we'll
check out father Mike schmitz's Bible in
a year podcast available on the hollow
app where you can play a pray alongside
Mark Wahlberg Jim Caviezel even world
famous athletes as well with how low you
can customize a personal prayer plan
that works for you listen wherever you
are with downloadable offline sessions
using hello to connect with others who
share your beliefs and values can
provide a sense of belonging support and
Foster a sense of community ultimately
we'll learn how we can become better
individuals in spite of today's broken
World As We strive to become more like
Christ in our daily lives through prayer
fasting and giving download Halo and
hello.com Matt walsher get an exclusive
three months free that's three months
absolutely free at hello.com Matt Walsh
not a lot of insight there but maybe if
you go to the view the view had uh had
dealt with this Jason Aldean song
yesterday and uh let's listen to what
they had to say maybe they'll have maybe
they'll have something more more
intelligent to offer we can always hope
this was to me something where about
half the people in my life see it one
way and half the people in my life see
it a different way so I'm trying to like
kind of see what are we disconnecting on
I'm going to give him the benefit of the
doubt that his intent wasn't to you know
Stoke division glorify violence or
racism I'm gonna give him that benefit
of the doubt I don't know but I'll say
this there was a line so for the many
folks who are offended by this there's a
line in it that says try that in a small
town see how far you make it down the
road around here we take care of our own
so for a lot of my friends and family
who are legal gun owners in small
communities they're like yeah that's
what we do someone breaks into a story
he's talking about the right to defend
yourself what I thought of when I read
that read that was a mod arbory I think
of a black man in a small town in the
South who literally just got shot for
doing nothing wrong so I think what
becomes problematic is that there's a
wreck there's a lack of recognition
about what this means to about 50
percent of the country whose experience
isn't Jason Aldean's I like him I've
always liked his music I'm kind of a
country gal about like a quarter of the
time but this is also for the folks on
the right who are defending this they
see the BLM riots many like I I think
many can acknowledge
protests and riots that George Floyd's
death and murder was evil it was wrong
it was unacceptable but so was the
killing of someone like David Dorne a
black retired police officer who was
defending his friend's store and was
shot during the riots and aftermath of
that movement so I think if people of
good faith can see both sides I can see
there is an issue with this song because
of what it means to a lot of communities
but there is an issue of violence of
Looting of Rights but why are you
linking it to black people well that's
what I think about that's the issue
issue the imagery is what becomes very
problematic
well once again uh
there's uh I guess we we gave it a shot
we gave it a shot to see if there's
anything insightful being said in the
view but apparently there isn't
um a long conversation those went on for
a long time in every every major media
Outlet all the shows have been talking
about this once again you're not going
to find this kind of uh conversation
about any other violent form of Music
which is which is a a shame because as I
said this is this is actually a
worthwhile conversation to have and you
could throw Jason Aldean's song into it
I'm fine no I think the song is fine I
don't I don't particularly like the
songs and I don't it's not something I'm
going to listen to myself I just don't
enjoy how it sounds uh the message is
fine but if you want to have a broader
like discussion about okay well you've
got you know your violence that's that's
uh portrayed in in movies and in TV
shows it comes up in music
um in many different contexts
when is it when is it a bad thing that
we should be worried about when is it
good is it always bad or is it always
fine does it never like we could these
are all things that we can talk about
but we can't do that
when you've just decided to give
again to take all the worst examples of
this and to give them all a pass
that's when it doesn't work
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there